[Music]
I already feel like I'm floating.
But I don't have anything to teach you
anymore I canceled the practical classes and it's not
fun If I can form a party with him, I'm a winner in life You
know that even after graduating from prep school and becoming an adventurer, you can continue to form
parties  It
seems like everyone is thinking the same thing,
but there
's something I need to talk to you about.
That's why I've been alone all this time That's really
it If you and I, who were the top scorers in martial arts, teamed up, would
n't you think he'd admit it?
] It's a
story that doesn't come to mind Lie
Kumaki 7
This is a child of borrowed scenery,
so please call me Erwin von Alnim I'm a non-nerd
Nieder
Nice to meet you
, why don't you use your courage?
My name
is Wu
Sanchang.
Should
I stop laughing now?